[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
the defendant kills witnesses after
weeks in court closing arguments begin
in the trial of real estate air robert
durst hear from the prosecution team who
say durst has spent his life running
from the truth plus new developments for
the free brittany movement as britney
spears's father petitions to be removed
from her conservatorship our legal
experts explain what that can mean for
the pop star and we're hearing from bill
cosby accuser andrea constand for the
first time since the comedian was
released from prison how she says his
release has affected her but first newly
released text messages pop up in the
wake of elizabeth holmes opening
statements i think these text messages
are going to be really helpful to the
prosecution and difficult for the
defense to overcome what the texts say
and why they may contradict the
defense's arguments law on crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin as the trial for theranow's
founder elizabeth holmes begins in
california new text messages come to
light that could undercut her defense
law and crimes anginet levy is here with
some of those texts
elizabeth holmes is accused of
defrauding investors with theranose's
blood testing technology she also is
claiming that she was misled about the
technology by her then boyfriend sonny
balwani and that he abused her but there
are some text messages from 2015 that
threatened to undercut that claim
text messages from may 12 2015 show that
holmes wrote to sunny balwani you are
breeze in desert for me my water and
ocean meant to be only together tiger
madly in love with you and your strength
the next day balwani wrote all my love
attorney heather hansen has followed the
case closely heather what do you make of
these new text messages that came out
between elizabeth holmes and sunny
balwani you know i always talk about
tone of voice being important and
jeanette but tone of text messages is
also important and when you listen to
and see these text messages it is pretty
clear from them that the relationship
that she describes as being abusive and
controlling and all of these things is
not there with what we've seen so far so
it depends on how the rest of the text
messages come out but for what i have
seen thus far i think these text
messages are going to be really helpful
to the prosecution and difficult for the
defense to overcome and that is a major
part of her defense that she was
an abused woman that he was you know had
her under his control and she was naive
and didn't know
yeah it's funny it's a new part of her
defense right it's something that we
just found out about recently and yes it
looks like it's going to be the crux of
her defense that he was abusive
physically emotionally psychologically
and that as a result she could not form
the intent she didn't intend to
defraud these people but rather intended
to keep him happy so far i have not seen
any text messages that support that
defense now there's things i'm sure we
haven't seen and i anticipate she will
take the stand to try to explain some of
this away but what i've seen so far is
not great news for the defense you wrote
a piece for law and crime.com in which
you you basically said she was able to
charm investors and now you're
questioning whether she can charm a jury
what does elizabeth holmes have to do
well it's a very i talk all the time
about we all have our juries and her
jury with the investors was the
investors that's who she wanted to
influence and persuade and here she has
an actual jury and they look very
different than her investors her jury
here ranges in age from 19 to 60. she
has men and women she has the majority
are caucasian but there are some
hispanic jurors there are a few asian
jurors all of these people look very
different from the investors that she
had that tended to be older white men
she needs to talk to them differently
they need to present it differently they
need to look at this case from the
perspective of a 19 year old a
all of these various personalities
that's going to be part of how she has
to advocate to this jury well very
interesting attorney heather hanson
thanks so much for joining us and we'll
send it back to you in the studio
thanks angenet joining us today is
criminal defense attorney bernardo
villalona and terry austin bernard how
are these text messages going to play
into this trial
brian you know from having trying cases
that the the reality is is that when
you're dealing with text messages that
at the time that you're sending text
messages you're not thinking that you're
going to be criminally charged you're
not thinking that these text messages
can actually be used against you at the
time of trump so these text messages are
going to play heavily against miss
holmes who was able to profit billions
of dollars on this so-called technology
and it's not going to work in her favor
yeah she definitely was not thinking
about a trial during that whole desert
breeze comment uh terry in opening
statements the defense led with the
prosecution is trying to make out a
crime from a failed startup do you see
that
happening or do you see that based on
the facts is that what's going on here
well i think they're trying to say that
but i don't think that's going to
prevail there's a big difference between
a failed startup and fraud it's okay to
have a company that doesn't succeed but
it's not okay it's a question of ethics
to lie to your investors about how the
company is doing she knew all along at
least it does seem that way that the
company was not doing well you can be
optimistic but you cannot portray that
you're making money that the tests are
going well when in fact that's not
happening this sounds a little bit like
enron and worldcom to me where it was
accounting fraud he or she basically is
trying to tell those investors who have
a lot of money and a lot of faith in her
that they're all doing well please keep
investing so that's the difference yeah
i mean puffery is definitely a type of
defense i've heard for fraud where the
greatest this where the best that when
you start saying our devices have been
shipped to
war zone areas different places and
different medical facilities that sounds
more like fraud but of course we'll keep
eyes on this case as it continues
new sound into our newsroom as bill
cosby accuser andrea constand speaks out
for the first time since the comedian's
release from prison
cosby was released from prison back in
june after serving three of his original
10-year sentence in 2018 cosby was
convicted on three felony counts of
aggravated indecent assault largely in
part to constant sexual assault
allegations constant told nbc news on
tuesday that though cosby was released
her statement against him was still
believed
well everybody has is entitled to their
own celebrations but it doesn't change
the fact that he's a sexually violent
predator and he will always be
[Music]
my rapist there was nothing happy for me
about
seeing somebody put in handcuffs and put
into a van and taken to jail it's all
sad
lives impacted
families ruined
you can watch constant's entire
exclusive interview courtesy of nbc news
still ahead of law and crime daily the
murder murder mystery continues after
reports of another shooting south
carolina suspends attorney alex
murdoch's law license but first
bombshell news in the free brittany
movement as the pop star's father
petitions to end her 13-year long
conservatorship what this could mean for
the pop star moving forward
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live lawn
crime network with youtube tv for all of
your daily live trial coverage legal
news expert analysis and original true
crime programs subscribe to youtube tv
today and then locate law and crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
britney spears's father files a petition
to end the pop stars conservatorship
the conservatorship dates back to 2008
following spears's public breakdown
since then her father james jamie spears
has held control over financial
decisions through a legal
conservatorship the conservatorship came
to light in recent years through the
so-called free brittany movement as fans
of the singer allege she is being
controlled by her father in the past two
years brittany has attempted to remove
her father from the conservatorship most
recently in june of this year alleging
jamie spears was abusive and that he
ruined her life last month brittany's
attorneys filed a petition to remove
jamie spears and replace him with a
professional accountant in the new
document filed tuesday jamie spears
requests removal from the
conservatorship saying brittany is quote
entitled to have this court now
seriously consider whether this
conservatorship is no longer required
jamie spears has repeatedly denied any
abuse towards his daughter
let's bring back criminal defense
attorney bernard velona and terry austin
to break down the newest twist in the
spears conservatorship terry
hey it's what britney spears wanted all
along but does the timing seem a little
suspicious
well it may not be suspicious brian but
it's definitely convenient he's stepping
down for a number of reasons not the
least of which is britney wants him to
step down and she has expressed that
repeatedly and then you mentioned the
movement trying to free britney that
public pressure has got to weigh down on
him he has to know as a father that he's
the one who the public is considering as
the bad guy and so i think that's part
of the reason her attorneys think that
he's trying to avoid the deposition
avoid accounting and frankly in my
opinion he should one step down and he
should do a full accounting she has
every right to see where her money has
been spent absolutely bernardo with
jamie asking for a reevaluation of
britney spears without a psychological
exam could this be the beginning of the
end of the conservatorship
so absolutely brian i find it quite
interesting that now that jamie spears
is no longer going to be in charge of
the conservative shifts he's like wait
hold up let's evaluate whether my
daughter even needs to continue with
this conservative shift because now that
jamie is out guess what he's not
receiving thousands of dollars per month
in order to manage this conservative so
i'm curious to see how this is going to
play out i will say this that an audit
needs to take place for everything that
has been done on behalf of britney
spears while jamie spears has been ahead
of this conservative ship absolutely an
audit would be very interesting to see
how those dollars and cents moved and
maybe there's something
behind all this smoke thank you both
turning now to more top legal news and
an update on the murdah murder mystery
south carolina supreme court is
suspending the law license of alex
murdoch
alex murdoch is accused of
misappropriating funds from his law firm
the attorney made national headlines
this summer after he called 9-1-1 to
report finding the bodies of his wife
maggie and their son paul shot dead on
the family's hunting property this
weekend murda again called 9-1-1 this
time to say he had been shot in the head
by passing vehicle he's now recovering
from his injury but the south carolina
supreme court acted quickly after his
firm reported his alleged
misappropriation saying murdoch is
suspended until further notice he
resigned on monday saying he was
entering rehab
and in georgia the former district
attorney handling the ahmad arbory case
has turned herself in to authorities
jackie johnson is charged with violating
her oath of office and obstructing and
hindering a law enforcement officer
according to the indictment johnson let
her favor and affection for gregory
mcmichael stand in the way of justice
gregory mcmichael along with his son
travis and co-defendant william rhodey
brian are accused of gunning down aubry
while he was jogging in a georgia
neighborhood
johnson was booked into the glenn county
detention center monday morning and
released on a ten thousand dollar bond
coming up on law and crime daily after
months of back and forth closing
arguments begin in the trial of robert
durst what you need to know as the
prosecution treaches forward in its case
against the real estate heir plus the
elijah mcclain family attorney speaks to
law and crime daily for the first time
since the officers involved in his death
were indicted how she hopes to curb
future deaths by law enforcement with
new legislation
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
we're hearing for the first time from
elijah mclean's family's attorney one
week after five first responders were
charged in connection to his death
you may remember elijah mclean was
killed back in 2019 when aurora colorado
police officers confronted him and
paramedics administered ketamine to
sedate him mclean a 23 year old black
man was wearing a ski mask at the time
and committed no crimes just last week
the colorado attorney general's office
secured a 32-account indictment against
the three officers and two paramedics
accusing them of manslaughter and
criminal negligent homicide i sat down
with mclean family attorney mari newman
who says she's proud to be part of a
case that will hold law enforcement
accountable take a listen
sure well the day before the indictments
were announced publicly the attorney
general's office of course called the
family out of courtesy and respect
and
and i can tell you about the
conversation between the attorney
general's office and elijah's dad lawyer
as soon as lewane heard the news
just broke down this is news he had been
waiting for for two years and so for him
it was i think a combination of
a sense of relief a sense that finally
there was going to be some
measure of accountability
you know these prosecutions are
important but they don't bring elijah
back and so for elijah's dad you know
it's bittersweet because
he still doesn't have his son but he was
thankful to the to the attorney
general's office and to the grand jury
for trying to do what is in their power
and that is to hold the officers and the
medics accountable the indictment of
these officers and paramedics is just
the beginning this is i know it's a huge
victory but it's just hopefully one of
many in this case so what's next both
for the the civil rights case but as
well as the criminal case against the
three officers and two paramedics
well obviously from the criminal side of
things they brought the charges but now
they need to prosecute them and so that
that process will be ongoing
in the context of the civil rights case
that case continues to be ongoing we're
litigating that in federal court and
then there's a
third investigation that's happening
here in colorado i'm very proud to have
been part of the team that passed uh
what's really been touted as the most
comprehensive police accountability bill
since the murder of george floyd that's
called colorado sb 217 and one of the
things that we did in that law was we
empowered the colorado state attorney
general to conduct investigations into
departments that have a pattern or
practice of brutality or discrimination
and based on that new law the colorado
attorney general also has
initiated
a investigation into the rural police
department which as you and i discussed
last time has a long-standing and
horrible uh pattern of both racism and
brutality that has gone on for decades
i've been suing them for decades and
surely
it began long before that and so that
investigation is also ongoing and my
hope is that that will result ultimately
in a consent decree which requires that
the auroral police department change in
meaningful ways so that no more lives
are lost
when we come back the highly anticipated
closing arguments begin in the trial of
robert durst we'll show you how the
prosecution blasts the accused murderer
and why they say he runs from the truth
and attacks his victims
[Music]
welcome back after four months of
testimony more than three weeks of the
defendant on the stand and a lot i mean
a lot of patience closing arguments
finally began in robert durst's murder
trial
robert durst is on trial for the murder
of his best friend susan berman who was
discovered dead in her benedict canyon
california home in december 2000. durst
is accused of murdering berman because
she supposedly had information about his
wife kathy another murder that he's also
accused of testimony was paused in march
2020 due to the pandemic and resumed in
may 2021 closing arguments began this
week with prosecutor habib balean
representing the state of california he
opened the arguments with the jokes that
jabbed at some of his teammates
some size
and it's hard to tell like
if those sighs were more like oh man
mr billion's given the argument
or like oh mr billion's given the
argument
but
do not worry
do not worry
mr lewin
gave me a list of some topics he wanted
me to cover so
[Laughter]
i'm joking of course mr million's here i
don't remember but when we started the
trial
this is what mr millions looked like
after the last cleared out of the
courtroom baillian got down to business
making a strong statement about why the
jury is there
why are we here why we have this trial
it could be anyone it could be officer
dean banner who he tried to get to the
glove box
for id which we know what id was in
there that idea was loaded with five
rounds of ammunition
it could have been off its officer dean
benner in me i had no choice it could
have been its catherine pier media or me
i had no choice the loss prevention
officer he also tried to get to that car
it could be anyone who stands between my
accountability or me
he has no choice
we're here because he kills witnesses
that's why we've had this trial the
defendant kills witnesses
or tries to kill witnesses or plans to
kill witnesses
the state then brought up a bizarre and
somewhat jarring image they say sums up
durst's tendency to lie
trust him when he's admitted to you he
lied and you know that he's lied to you
about many things and you know they're
important things and you know that they
would be the things that involve the
central issues in this case can you
trust him
let me ask you this say you go
to a restaurant
and you order a bowl of soup
and your soup comes this is going to be
a little gross but i think it
it adequately illustrates this point
and your soup comes and this is what you
find in it
do you just pick out that bug that
cockroach
toss it aside and say you know what i'm
just gonna finish this soup
this is what was served to you
literally you were served a bowl of
cockroaches
and you were told you pick out which
ones are bad and which ones are good you
toss them aside but you can trust the
rest of that soup go ahead and eat it up
lap it up
bernardo you've done plenty of closing
arguments how's the prosecution doing so
far
so i think they're doing okay however i
have to think that look this trial has
been going on for days for weeks for
months so in order to encapsulate
everything that has taken place they
have to hit the major points and i think
one point that they have failed to miss
in this case is that look robert thirst
as he sits at the defense table he looks
like he's going to croak over and die
any day they need to remind the jury
that when these murders took place
robert durst was much younger much
stronger
much much more expressive during that
time than he is today as he sits before
you and i think what the prosecution
just needs to continue continue going
with that the case is about the nine
words it was either her or me they he
had to make a choice and he made that
choice and just keep hitting that nail
on the head so this jury knows that when
they go back and deliberate they even
despite the weeks and months of
testimony that this case is very simple
he had to do what he needed to do in
order to remain a free man in the
streets absolutely terry what did you
think of this cockroach approach by the
prosecution can the defense bring up any
reasonable doubt after that
i actually think balian did an excellent
job so far and the cockroach analogy was
excellent if you have a cockroach in
your soup you are not going to eat the
rest of it you're going to send it back
because it's tainted and you can't eat
any of it just like you're not going to
believe as a jury anything this man has
to say excellent analogy he was doing a
great job all right watch out for
cockroaches in your soup and we'll talk
to you later thank you for joining us
here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you